Dear President Vladimir Putin,
I'm so sorry that I was not your mother.
You plan a trip, you want to go there. I want to go to Italy for
four years, I haven't been able to
make it because of
the pandemic.
And now this, you know, it's like,
who's going to—what's going to
happen there?
But at the same time, he's
being compelled by God.
Whenever something earth-shattering and awful happens,
we've come to expect grifters,
celebrities, and attention whores
to go to the mattresses with the
dumbest and most self-obsessed
takes imaginable.
That's all well and good.
Viva free speech.
But we shouldn't stand for that from
the serious people, the policymakers, activists, and media figures who keep telling us how
smart, informed, and wise they are.
That's especially true
when we're talking about actual war.
So here's a word to the would be wise:
you don't have to serve up glib, instamatic
replies that would make Joy Behar wince
in the hopes of building a consensus for your
preexisting obsessions.
The Democratic Socialists of
America, whose ranks include
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
and Bernie Sanders, don't have to
rush into print to blame America
first when Vladimir Putin
defies international law.
Former Wisconsin governor and
perennial Republican presidential
contender Scott Walker doesn't
have to turn a hot war into a
hot take about Joe Biden
and immigration, of all things.
Supposedly sober journalists like NBC's chief
foreign correspondent Richard Engel,
don't have to float trial balloons
about blowing up Russian convoys
and starting World War three.
John Kerry, Joe Biden's special
envoy for climate change, doesn't
have to drag the topic immediately
back to the melting Arctic
ice pack.
I hope President Putin will help us to stay on track
with respect to what we need to do
for the climate.
State liquor authorities in Virginia, Oregon,
Utah, Ohio, and New Hampshire
don't have to rush to ban Russian
alcohol from store shelves.
Democratic members of Congress, like
Eric Swalwell, don't have to propose
kicking every Russian student out
of the United States right this very moment.
And Republicans like Adam Kinzinger can just say no
to no-fly zones.
That would be an absolute act of war.
War hysteria is a real thing,
and it drives decent people to
stupidity, madness and worse.
When America declared war on Germany
during World War One,
people all over the country killed
dachshunds out of patriotic fervor.
Walter Jones was the North Carolina congressman who got the
House cafeteria to rename french fries
freedom fries after France refused to join our 2003
invasion of Iraq.
Within a couple of years,
he regretted not just his culinary intervention,
but his support for
Operation Iraqi Freedom.
And he spent the rest of his life
apologizing for a catastrophic
military action based on
bad intelligence.
War is complex and filled with
unexpected outcomes.
Will the rush, say, to cut every day Russians out of the
global economic system have its
intended effect?
Or will it simply increase the scale
of human suffering and the resolve
of the aggressor?
Past wars teach us the folly of
quick decisions and courses of
action informed by bad
information and emotion.
Our elites, especially
our elected leaders, can leave
the glibness to the rest of us
and maybe, just maybe
think before they swarm social media
like Russian tanks driving deep
into Ukraine.